then
let me remind you of two ministerial
meetings that are taking place today
hiv-p joseph borrel will chair an
informal meeting of defence ministers
at 12 30.
they will discuss how to respond to the
call for military assistance to the
ukrainian armed forces
and ways to step up our military support
a press conference by the high
representative will take place
at around 2 30 pm
likewise
energy ministers
will meet this afternoon
commissioner kelly simpson will be there
to represent the commission
ministers will discuss the consequences
of the russian invasion of ukraine on
the energy market
and its impact on the eu
a press conference is foreseen at the
end of the meeting
at around 5 30 pm with the participation
of commissioner simpson
we invite you to address your questions
on defense specific issues
and on energy
to these respective
press conferences
and with this
the floor
is yours
let me give the floor
to
esm
um hi eric i have a question uh for uh
foreign relations and um sanctions so we
know that the bosnian herzegovina and
serbia are only two countries who um
didn't join eu when it comes to um
sanctions
so what is the commission's comment on
that and the other one is we know that
the sputnik is operating in serbia how
that issue will be
um
raised or um
done by european uh commission when it
comes to the sanctions regarding russia
today and
sputnik thank you
thank you very much on on your second
question related to russia today and to
sputnik
um let me stress that we are currently
working on the practical modalities to
ensure that um this decision can be
implemented um obviously this is a
decision that concerns the territory of
the european union
on the first question uh anna do you
have a comment um yes i would probably
uh just refer you to the uh statements
that hrvp made yesterday uh you know
after the um extraordinary uh fact uh
meeting where he uh basically uh
explained that of course we will be uh
following the positions of um you know
candidate countries when it comes to
enlightenment uh of uh you know to um to
um to the eu uh foreign policy um i
think that uh both the president has
also made clear that we're at a
watershed uh moment um you know what is
at stake um we've said it is is the
stability um of europe and the whole um
international order uh our peace and and
and uh president putin i think we've uh
already had the chance to say many times
that he has chosen uh the to bring back
war uh to europe and uh we all know that
our unity and determination to act is
our strength and this is why the
european union together with um its uh
partners has taken strong uh measures in
response to russia's actions and in
support of ukraine uh and uh it will
also do as well and it has done in the
case of belarus
and again canada countries such as
serbia are expected of course to align
with the eu uh decision and position on
foreign policy and security matters
in short
we expect all countries that uh want to
have closer relations with the european
union
and to
align
on our sanctions policy
yes
yes thank you i actually have two
different questions the one is another
country that is not aligned yet on
sanctions is switzerland there reports
that there is pressure on switzerland to
to
to follow
your sanctions can you confirm that is
it from your side or other other players
putting pressure on switzerland on this
and the second one there is a discussion
about ukraine
uh
becoming a candidate country for
membership
could you please clarify
how the procedure would be thank you
thank you on your first question i think
we have made it abundantly clear over
the past weeks that we are coordinating
very closely with all our allies friends
and partners
including with switzerland and
we know that the effectiveness of
sanctions
will be all the greater
uh the more coherent and the more
comprehensive
the lists of countries that apply
these these sanctions and therefore we
look forward to switzerland uh applying
um the sanctions or the same type of
sanctions that we have decided with a
broad
range of partners
um
in order to achieve
that
that objective
on
your second question
um i have seen many comments on the
debate surrounding
ukraine's
membership of the european union
you know that the president
commented
on this yesterday when asked
she
referred clearly to the fact that
ukraine has a european perspective it is
one of us in the sense that it is a
european country
and then she specified that there is a
process
and the process i think you know very
well when it comes
to
the accession negotiations
that take place in order to
fulfill the conditions for uh for
accession but she has also specified
that we are deepening
our relations
with and have been deepening for a long
time our relations
with ukraine
in particular through the association
agreement and the linked dc fta that
this includes and for example she
mentioned energy and the fact that we
are
integrating
working to integrate their energy in
particular their electricity grid with
that of the eu
right um i will simply i think all your
questions must be relating to events at
the moment stefan follow up
yes just uh two short follow-ups uh on
the first one i'm having in mind that
switzerland is an important financial
place in the middle of europe uh this
reluctance from the swiss government to
follow the eu sanction justice in a way
influence uh the relationship with
switzerland and secondly if i understand
right uh president zelinski said he
wants some kind of a fast track
procedure toward membership what does
this i mean
what your
view thank you
on your first question um
quite frankly
our attention at the moment is focused
on uh our relationship with ukraine
and everything that
both we the european union and our
international partners
can do to support ukraine
and we can only wish
and hope
that switzerland will join this effort
because it as you say it is indeed
an important
actor in particular when it comes to
financial services which are
specifically targeted by many of the
measures that we have announced these
past these past days
and
i
as i said i sincerely hope that we
sincerely hope that switzerland will
live up to the moment
that we are living through
on your second question um
again coming back to uh to the issue of
membership and special procedures well
this is not really a question for us you
know the role of the commission when it
comes to negotiation processes we
actually carry out the negotiations on
behalf of the eu
but the negotiation process per se is
not something that we the european
commission said so i'm not in a position
to comment on this
yes mates
um yeah i do have a follow-up on what
the president vanderlei said in the
interview i don't think she just
explained the process i think she
clearly said we want ukraine to become a
member of the european union and i was
wondering
who are the wee she was talking about is
that
her personal view is that the commission
is that the whole european union because
i can
imagine that some member states have
different thoughts on this
thank you
thank you very much
the the president uh expressed a view
which uh i think
is uh
extremely
um
general extremely well shared sorry
that's not the right word
that is that
ukraine is one of us as she expressed it
it is a european country
and
we want them in meaning europe in
general and if you look at
what we are seeing
across europe at the moment in terms of
demonstrations of support for the
country
it is clear that people
believe that
ukraine is at the heart of europe
but she then also specified that there
is a process
and i think that this is the important
point
this is what i can say matisse
yes sorry to to to come back to this i
want to have it absolutely she said i
think we want we want them to become a
member
i heard you saying now something
different explaining is a bit different
i understand this he also wants to show
the solidarity with ukraine i really
understand that maybe she went too far
with this specific phrase are you
backtracking a little bit on this we
want them to become a membership
member sorry
no no she spoke as president of the
european commission she expressed a view
as president of the european commission
and that is abundantly clear
um but she also
clearly basically said there is a
process for this to happen you know it
is not the president of the european
commission on her own who decides
when ukraine becomes a candidate and
what is the process to be followed for
it to become a candidate
but she expressed her view very clearly
on
the ultimate
outcome
that you would like to see
so i think that that is abundantly clear
priselda
micro
hello thank you nicholas wallace
um
i um
i i have two questions both on russian
propaganda and the first is
thierry breton's call
yesterday with google and youtube
and you know he he said that he hoped to
see them take tough measures i wanted to
ask whether
he was able to actually agree any
specific measures
with google and youtube yesterday and my
second question relates to the letter
which you may have seen that's been sent
by the prime ministers of poland latvia
lithuania and estonia
which has
seven quite specific recommendations
to google youtube facebook and twitter
on
um
basically taking down russian propaganda
accounts uh russian state-run media
accounts
and have you seen this letter and if so
does this uh reflect the position of the
european commission does it have the
backing of the european commission thank
you
johannes
um thank you eric
yes on there on the call that took place
yesterday between uh vice president very
eurovis commissioner
and the ceos of youtube suzanne
and um and
google santa pichai um they therefore
discussed the urgent need for taking
stronger actions to counter russian
state-sponsored disinformation and to
comply with sanctions including the
latest measures and there was agreement
to keep adopting and updating
the platform's policies in light of the
current situation
i'm also happy to share direct quotes
with with you maybe in writing um
there's no way let's say
a specific basically um
or a specific result in in terms of what
they will exactly do
it's important to know that there is
already a lot going on on the from the
sides of the platforms
you know that we have a framework
more generally the commission with the
platforms which is the code of practice
and where these things are also also
discussed and there's also work on going
as you know on there on a let's say
bolstered new code of practice but on
this specific meeting they agreed to
remain in touch on the issue
and i think it was important for dvp and
for the commissioner to um have this
personal call to um
you know
to establish also this direct link at
the highest level and and discuss these
issues um
as part of the letter yes we are aware
of the letter and uh
and this i think
reply in a way is already what i already
gave to you so uh the issue of
disinformation is very important one
that eric has already mentioned um
or responded to a question on the on
this personal question today
announcement that the president made
yesterday so all this you need to see in
a context thank you
thank you
we continue generally on the situation
with ukraine not segmenting by
sub-subject or else it would be very
complicated go ahead
thank you very much just to follow up to
the sputnik question
could you maybe just elaborate a little
bit about is is it a technical issue
that you're trying to work out or a
legal issue of both
thank you um no we're looking for the
best legal way to ensure that we can
reach our uh our objective there may
also be technical considerations at play
to be honest i'm not
fully aware of all the details but
definitely
we are looking at the best way to ensure
that we come to the uh to an effective
decision in this respect
okay i will go back to the interaction
platform
hi uh yeah thank you i i have two
questions follow up the first one
regarding the russian media i mean first
i mean the rationale basically i mean
are you worried if you actually carried
forward
that the
eu media i mean for example will be
retaliated i mean you were triggered
for that media war that is uh you know
for the old journalists here maybe from
eu in danger uh second uh you know i
don't know how can you argue i mean you
advocate this freedom of press
and now you i mean basically you say i
mean you don't like it i know i mean the
russian media but the same thing in eu
the left and the right media they don't
like each other in the u.s fox news and
cnn accused each other of this
information so the fact that e rt has
existed in eu member states for many
many years so
shows that you or your member states
have accepted that i mean it's okay so
why i mean
you do it now i mean it's not violating
your freedom speech of press thank you
thank you very much for your for your
questions
um when it comes to retaliating against
eu media in russia
quite frankly when you see the state of
play of media freedom in russia and the
actual information that russian citizens
have access to
the russians
are a long long long way ahead
um
so
from that point of view there's
absolutely no context basically it is
extremely difficult if not impossible
for russian citizens to have access to
any type of
free and objective media and in
particular european or international
media
in general
so
that's that's one thing
the second point about
sputnik and russia today what has
changed
well i think you see the images of what
has changed every day on television
the fact is that
we consider that these two media
are a part of the russian war effort in
ukraine
and that they are
promoting
views on this conflict which are
entirely
um controlled by the russian apparatus
by the russian state
and that therefore they in no way
represent
any sort of media
that try to try to provide balanced
coverage oh yeah i'm sure that is
something that you understand
but they are basically uh propagating
the views of the kremlin
um and therefore in that context
we are taking measures not against the
media we are taking measures against a
propaganda channel
or propaganda channels that is the
difference
but of course we value
the freedom of media um very much and
that is why these are steps that are not
taken lightly and that are taken only in
very
exceptional circumstances
such as a war of aggression against the
sovereign country
let me continue dafid
[Music]
hi is this working it is it is okay um
uh fondue lion
last week i think was it on friday or
whatever um
mentioned the importance
of um stopping the export of technology
certain technologies to russia she
spec she zoomed in on the refinery
russian refineries
and mentioned the 24 billion
amount of trade um of russian refineries
refined products coming into the eu and
said there were harsh sanctions
now the the sanctions were published uh
late on friday on the 25th
we've gone through the sanctions
they will have very little effect in
this specific area
they don't back they don't seem to ban
catalysts
they ban
major pieces of equipment which will
take 10-15 years to work through
um in having an effect on the russian
refinery industry i was wondering is
are catalysts actually banned or is
there some
error in reading the regulation
to straight daffod you're asking me
specifically whether catalysts
are on the list of sanctions
um
oh no sorry tim i'm not sure you have
the list with you we will need to come
back to you on that very specific
product which i'm sure is very important
um
but let you
remind you of the broader picture
um and of the comments that we made at
the time now this was
these sanctions were proposed and
approved
on the basis of a completely different
situation at the time president putin
had
just announced that he was
recognizing um the
independence
of
the luhansk and donetsk oblast which are
part
of ukraine
um and at the time when we adopted these
sanctions we were very clear the
president was very clear that the
objective
was to erode
the capacity of russia's energy sector
over
time why
because
it is clear that
in the european union
the regulations
continue
to evolve
the environmental
conditions which are set on industrial
products when it comes to energy use or
on cars or whatever continue to evolve
and therefore
the russian energy industry needs to be
able
to offer us products which meet these
criteria
and our belief is that over time
by depriving the russian energy sector
of access to the technologies that we
have mentioned
in the sanctions list
they will
no longer be progressively in a position
to meet
the stringent criteria of the energy
market
prevailing in europe this is not from
one day to the next that is absolutely
true and we have never presented
otherwise now
of course
sanctions
are adopted at one specific point in
time since then
as you have seen
the situation on the ground has evolved
dramatically
and so have our sanctions
augustine
thank you dude
i heard you and i no longer hear you go
ahead
do you hear me eric yeah i do
yeah okay uh i have a question on um two
questions on enlargement basically the
the procedures are there but we remember
from the big enlargement in 2004 that
the procedures
and decisions can be adapted to the
political will at that time there was a
political will in europe to unite the
europe
so they didn't look too much into the
conditionality
many former members of the commission
admitted that they knew that several
countries were not fully ready but it
was political decision to take them back
in now
it's a
new time uh historic time for europe
can eu decide politically
to have a enlargement as a peace project
not just as a
technical
box ticking exercise that it's now on
just to remind you that former yugoslav
republic of macedonia which is now north
macedonia
applied uh
10 12 years ago to join ten years ago to
join eu and it has hazard start even the
accession talks and it is already member
of nato same with albania so promising
ukraine
at this time because we know that they
are fighting for entire europe
can in the long term
seem to be a little bit misleading or
are there negotiations going on within
you at the highest level uh to to to do
some differences in the enlargement
process and second question again it's
on serbia
many times we saw that uh
augustine could we please take one
question at a time because it's already
very long and i believe you know you
have to
you have to bear with us when it comes
also to our capacity
to answer appropriately so we'll take
this question first and then i'll give
you the floor again on serbia on your
question related to
a promise on the process
um now
what
the president
has clearly
lined out
is a
perspective
which is one which i think we all agree
applies even according to the treaties
to
[Music]
to countries that are in europe and that
live up to the values of article 2 and
promote them
then when it comes to the process
she has reminded
us
through this interview that she gave
interview that there is indeed a process
for this negotiation and she has not
said anything about deviating from the
process now we know that there are calls
we have heard the message from president
zielinski calling for
a um
an accelerated
fast-tracked
procedure but again as i say let me
remind you that the commission
works on the basis of a mandate that it
receives to negotiate
we do not define the mandate ourselves
and in that sense um you know i fully
understand your questions and again
we um
we stand in solidarity with ukraine but
the process is not something that the
commission itself defines it works based
on the process that exists now
all that being said
i also hear you when you speak of the
enlargement process that is ongoing
with the current
candidate countries and i believe you
have heard the president
repeat an extremely
extremely high number of times
how much she values and supports
the
the enlargement process vis-a-vis these
candidate countries in the welcome
western balkans and if there is
one person who has been doing everything
in her power to try to ensure that these
negotiations can proceed as quickly as
possible
it is the president of the european
commission
right
now i come back to your question on
serbia
yes thank you
uh in several conclusions uh even at the
summits of eu it was stated that
membership in eu should be a strategic
choice of the candidate country and they
should behave based on this
serbia publicly said that they are not
going to support eu sanctions on russia
so saying that we expect candidate
countries to align
worked until now on different issues
while serbia doesn't have a good track
record on that but that's not a point
because this is something completely
different so do you concretely expect
serbia to align with eu sanctions
against russia
and if not what will be the consequences
because we hear even the proposal to
suspend accession negotiations thank you
thank you
i think it applies what i said earlier
applies to all our
all our
friends neighbors and partner countries
and we
believe that
we are in a historic moment
that action needs to take place now
and we invite
all
our friends neighbors and partners
to apply
sanctions
in a coordinated and comprehensive
in comprehensive
manner
now there is an enlargement process
which takes place
it's a process it's not a one-off it's
not one decision
by this or that country that actually um
defines what is the end result of this
of this enlargement of this negotiation
process but it is clearly stated i
believe uh and i turn to my colleagues
for confirmation that we expect
candidate countries to align with our
external policy positions be they
statements or be they measures which are
adopted by the european union this is a
process over time it's not 100
immediately but there must be
forward positive movement in terms of
increasing the degree of alignment and
this is all that we can say today on
this subject
let me continue
daniel
can you hear me
yes go ahead all right can you hear me
now
yes can you hear me
no
we can hear you can you hear us
yes i can thanks
can you tell me following the
home affairs ministry uh council
yesterday what is the status of
extending
um the stay for ukrainians beyond 90
days i mean there have been these
comments about three years where does
that stand please thanks
thank you this is a question for anita
thank you i think you're referring to
the temporary protection directive since
2001 indeed we confirmed that
discussions have taken place uh
yesterday at the extraordinary justice
and home affairs council and the
commissioner commissioner johansson has
already said that work is on the way to
to prepare
the triggering of the directive as an
option of support
thank you
we continue and i apologize to my
colleagues for making you come on and
off the podium but it would be difficult
to
organize otherwise jigo
thank you so much so um two short
questions to come back to the membership
request have you see have you received
anything from kiev um
regarding membership
you received another and the second
question is yeah eric you said the
commission has no say in the process
but it's it's not really true since i
mean two years ago
you um
the commission proper made a proposal
for a new methodology um of the
accession process are you planning
anything
like this to um because you could
propose a fast track that then would be
discussed in council or whatever is
there anything in the pipeline thank you
thank you on your first question i'm not
aware of us having received a formal a
formal request anna
but as you can imagine
the ukrainian authorities
have
an invasion to repel and therefore
i believe that we have certainly heard
the calls from president uh zelinski
which is of course in uh in itself an
important statement
but on the uh on having received
specific requests i do not know yes so
just to clarify the procedure the
procedures i mean applications for
membership are not sent to the
commission they are sent to the council
um and uh to our knowledge there has not
been so far there has not been a formal
uh request sent by ukraine but again
you know
if
something arrives it would be in the
council
thank you on your second question um on
the process you want to say something on
that um well on the second question i
think that again is as eric made very
clear
i don't think it's for us now to preempt
possible next steps um i think that
this is a discussion first and foremost
at the highest political level so for
the european council and i don't think
that it is it would be appropriate for
us to to to to pre-jump steps that need
to be taken i think that the zettic and
as the president herself mentioned i
mean there's uh very clear procedures
for this in place and at the end of the
day this is a debate at the highest
political level for for the council
thank you anna
we continue thomas
thank you it's on swift
what can and will you do
if
as a result of the blocking of swift
alternative channels and systems are you
are used can you act against this
circumventing and also
i wonder what kind of uh
form the decision will take because
swift is in essence a private belgian
society and in the board there are
private banks i understand this is a
technical question but i don't know if
you're going to give us a technical
briefing so i try my luck here thank you
bye
thanks i believe we already gave a
technical briefing on this i don't know
if this specific question uh was
addressed or not
but um
in any case when it comes to uh
circumvention with swift i'll call him
but let me say a couple of things um as
introduction
the first is that
everybody knows that swift is not the
only way that you can
that you can conduct financial
transactions
but the fact is that it is
by far the most
efficient and quick and secure way
of conducting financial transactions and
this is why this is a system
which is by far the global dominant
inter bank messaging system that
processes such payments
so
banks that
are shut out of um
of swift
can certainly try to find other ways you
know fax machines uh alternative systems
but they definitely do not have
the same um the same speed
um and low cost and security as
as swift as swift has
with that i pass the floor to ayanna
thank you eric i'll try to add some
information for as much as i can
indeed the decision uh
well there has been a proposal presented
on ensuring that a certain number of
banks are removed from swift we
understand that this is uh being adopted
uh
very soon so the details will be uh
available later eventually of course
you're welcome to touch base um once
this has actually happened to have a
technical information as far as we have
not provided already in the past what i
can add in general on eu sanctions is
that council decisions are binding on
new member states council regulations
are a legal act of general application
and therefore they're binding on any
person or entity under eu jurisdictions
it's the member states that are
responsible for the implementation of eu
sanctions as well as identifying
breaches and imposing penalties
we are of course the guardian of the
treaties and therefore we have to ensure
the uniform implementation of eu law and
we monitor the enforcement of it by the
the member states
thank you
we continue closed
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
removed
yesterday uh joseph
announced
500 million
defense assistance and the eu will
deliver to ukraine
today i have seen on twitter so on by
some ukrainian media accounts that
slovakia and
[Music]
bulgaria and poland will deliver some
fight chats so actually some soviet-made
fighter checks that ukrainians can
handle
um to to ukraine my question is can you
confirm this do you have any knowledge
about this is this a part of the eu
package
and maybe can you
give some further details
what it will include and for instance
also if it will include if it could
include also
turkish-made
drones um i think the name is by um by
dr jones thank you
thanks
very much
when it comes to
fighter jets
ukrainian needs are dire
and
our member states are already doing a
lot and can consider the request of jet
fighters made by the minister kuliba
yesterday at the g7
meeting of foreign so this is ready to
answer your question as for the latest
that you were talking about i'm not sure
i i heard about the
the
the decision by lithuania to to do it
but under the epf we will definitely
strengthen the ukrainian armed force
capability to defend their territory and
population and you've heard the hrvp
yesterday
and the announcement of a package of 500
million under the upf
450 being
lethal and 50 being
non-lethal the epf can support for
example the delivery of arms ammunition
guns anti-tanks air defense etc
and the eu through its military staff
will act as a clearing house
and coordinate with member states the
needs of the ukrainian armed forces
so remo i think
you know things are evolving very very
quickly and your your
your questions your detailed questions
are absolutely
um are absolutely legitimate uh we will
see at how we can progressively uh
provide further detail when it comes to
what we will be
financing under the european peace
peace facility so watch this space
i may add something i mean there is a
foreign foreign affairs council defense
taking place as we speak right now and
of course ministers of defense will uh
assess the situation and speak about
this too
very true thanks for reminding us all of
that
david
thank you eric david price your
democracy um
i
i wonder if you could give us a little
bit more background on
the reason why the
public's right
to have all sorts of information is
being curtailed
um
you mentioned there's an exceptional
case because of a war but
during the whole of the cold war
soviet and communist propaganda was very
strong much stronger than
the
media being talked about
and the western europe actually
grew stronger because it could pick
apart
propaganda
um
so i'm wondering if you could give us
some reasons exactly why
the this very
fundamental right of the public to have
information from all sources is being
curtailed
my second question is
um about
the
european
union and before that the european
community is known as a zone of peace
and it ended uh
2000 years of war in western europe
and i'm wondering why the european union
is now taking sides in a war between
what are as far as i remember
two non-member states
um are not taking the role of being an
arbiter and a peacemaker between the two
states
um
what is the reason why the uh
these two states which are amongst the
most corrupt in europe uh ukraine is the
122nd most corrupt state in the world
and you uh russia is not far behind
uh so could you tell me why
european union is giving up its
obvious role as peacemaker
thank you for your too um for your two
questions um
the first thing uh i think i can say is
that the right to information
um is
to providing information is not absolute
there are always member states laws and
regulations
that
that define this right
in order to avoid a certain number of
things like hate speech for example
the second thing is that we have
regulators who look at these
at these things and
johannes is reminding me that they have
in the past already taken measures
against
these
these two media and these two media
outlets um your point is a very serious
one indeed
david and we do not underestimate
um the
the necessity
and the the paramount importance of
maintaining freedom of speech and
freedom of information in europe
beyond a shadow of a doubt
um
the point that is being made and that
will certainly be argued in whatever
legal instrument we it is that we
propose ultimately
is that we are now in a situation where
these two media
are actually
not complying with the basic principles
that pertain to a freedom of information
and freedom of media
so i invite you to wait until we come
forward with our concrete uh proposal
and then you will see how we argue this
in
in specific terms
when it comes to artificial intelligence
if i just may add also david is that i
mean there are also serious questions
about
calling them media i would remind you
that the editor-in-chief for example of
rt
margarita simonian has said that rt was
and i quote fighting an information war
against the whole western world i mean
when you say something like this
i i doubt that we can define them as a
media or independent media
the general argument we're making david
is that they are part of the kremlin's
war machine they're apart they are
propaganda
instruments for
for russia
and from that point of view can fall in
the scope of the type of sanctions that
we are working on
on your second question um
i leave to you the entire responsibility
of your comments as to um
as to um
ukraine um when it comes to um when it
comes to the fight against against
corruption
and i believe quite frankly that it is
out of place
you have a country that has been working
with the european union for years now
in order to improve the state of its
democracy
no democracy is perfect democracy is a
path it is not a state
it is something that you work on day by
day and this is precisely why in the
european union as well we have processes
and that we have discussed here many
many times in order to defend
the rule of law
and try to address the issues and
improve the state of the uh of the rule
of law
but
there are questions
let's be clear of life and death
and
ukraine is a country which is under an
existential threat and i think that the
overwhelming reaction
across europe and you have seen it in
the public reactions
is one of complete support for ukraine
in view of a completely
unjustified and
horrendous
invasion
and in
in that context the european union is
trying to restore peace
restore peace
it is not us who have decided of the
events that are taking place in ukraine
but we have always said that we stood by
the ukrainian people this is a country
with whom we have signed an association
agreement it is not a neutral country it
is a country with whom we have signed an
association agreement
it is a country with which we have been
working
uh to integrate our economies it is a
countries whose residents
come to the european union uh if he's a
free it is a country whose energy
systems we are integrating with ours
and it is a country that aspires to join
the european union as its president from
an embattled city of kiev reminded us
all this morning
and in that context
i think there is
an overwhelming
um overwhelming feeling that we need to
to help ukraine with whatever means
we have
and again we are
against war we believe that the european
union as you quite rightly pointed out
is the most successful peace project
in the history of mankind
but there is a paradigm shift when it
comes to the security situation in
europe
um it has started in ukraine but as you
can read everywhere and as we all
acknowledge it is not limited to ukraine
and therefore europe is acting in
defense of ukraine in defense of
democracy and in defense of europe
sandor
thanks eric yesterday prime minister
orban said that uh despite the eu
sanctions he would like to go on with
his uh
russian hungarian nuclear
deal to build pak2 reactors as far as i
understand one of the financing russian
banks veb
is under eu sanctions so my question is
are you looking at this
issue and is there any tools or any
opinion whether or not
russia should be able to build a nuclear
reactor on eu territory in the coming
years thank you
thank you sandor i'm
i'm afraid we're not able to answer
that very specific question uh from the
podium
from the podium now
and
you see that
the gist of our relations with russia at
the moment goes in a completely
different direction
but of course we are dealing with a very
very
immediate
crisis the invasion of ukraine
we certainly hope
that
we will be able to
see an improvement that the russian
troops will go back to their home bases
that peace negotiations will take place
and be successful and that
that we can
that we can then on a renewed basis look
at
long-term relationships
in a different light but at the moment
it is clear that our focus is on
supporting ukraine to repel the invasion
and we were all member states were
united
on this actually this is very important
to to remember to remind you
thank you
leo
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
um
david i come back to you
but i'm not going to get engaged in the
debate okay
thank you eric this is
basically slightly different questions
it's
[Music]
relative to the
what's called the
propaganda war or
war machine
the russians are saying that uh
what is lacking in the west
is an understanding of what's been
happening over the last eight years
where fourteen thousand people
have died
and
not nothing much has been said in uh
western media
and there's a need to actually have
access for the western european public
to have access or the west have access
to what's going on
secondarily
i asked a question last week about
russia's war aims and i was not able to
get a reply but if we have
a flow of information
it is the best way to understand
uh
how we can resolve the situation whether
it's energy protection of uh
civilians uh who are being bombarded and
so on but if we cut off
access to information
we're going to have a much longer longer
drawn out war than
is foreseen because we're acting out of
ignorance
so um
my plea is uh is
at least to have an understanding how
the
the decisions are made that uh
seem to be against the public's interest
to cut out sources of information and
secondary how can we actually define
what russia is up to and access to
information is not about emotion
i wonder whose side we're on look let me
make one thing extremely clear
this classroom is not about you stating
points of view repeatedly on the same
issue
okay you ask a question we provide an
answer
and i will be very strict on this
um
yours you can ask follow-up questions as
much as you want but please do not abuse
the time of your colleagues in ours to
repeat the same positions you have
already
expressed okay
in particular in this point in time
where we are all so extremely busy
now
on
your point
concerning
russia and the fact that russia claims
there is no information on what is
happening in the um luhansk donetsk
basically in the in the donbass now if
you expect us here on the podium
to answer every claim that is me but
that is made by the kremlin
um uh
you are you are mistaken we are usually
do not comment on the comments from
third parties and it applies even more
so to the uh claims
of a very varied nature that are made
by the kremlin but
i think that
simply from my own experience
looking at the media i have seen a lot
of reports about what is going on over
the past years in that
in that region
so
i believe that the european media have
been doing an outstanding job at trying
to inform the european public in an
objective manner on what is um on what
is happening there it may not please
the kremlin
and it may believe that we are not
informed the way it would like us to be
informed but i believe that european
citizens have
access to the news and the information
that they need on the situation
on the situation there if you want to
add
i may add something also david i would i
would dare to hope that that russian
media is not only
rt and sputnik
there are a lot of russian journalists
who are actually
providing information and this is even
if
after this they are being arrested by
uh the kremlin so i would
i would also give credit to all these
journalists who are doing their work in
depth independently
and it's not rt and sputnik who would
who are the source of information
and it might be good if the content
started by informing its own citizens
its own people
about what
it is actually doing currently in
ukraine because the reports we have is
that if there is one side of this
conflict that doesn't know what is
happening it's the russians
on
russia's or i would rather say putin's
war aims this is a question that you
have to ask to him
we
we know one thing it was clearly not
just about
donetsk and luhansk and we believe it is
also
not only about ukraine
and this is why the european reaction
and the international reaction as you
can see is
so strong
right i see
for the moment
no
further hands raised
and therefore i would like to end
today's midday briefing
with a little message
addressed to the people of
ukraine very very short because i'll say
it in english and in ukrainian
do you understand how hard the situation
is
for the people
of ukraine
we are
at your side
with that we close today's midday
briefing and we will see you tomorrow
thank you very much